حينما يحارب الإرهاب تقفز /واشنطن/ إلى المقدمة لتقبض على الراية
وإذا كانت الولايات المتحدة سوقت نفسها كفارس للحروب الضرورية، وفق تعبير /باراك أوباما/، فإن هناك أسئلةً لابد من طرحها قبل قياس نزاهة النوايا الأمريكية.
مصادر استخبارية أمريكية أحصت المقاتلين الأجانب في صفوف ما يسمى بالدولة الاسلامية باثني عشر ألف مقاتل من إحدى وثمانين دولة، في عِدادهم ما يتراوح بين ألفين إلى ثلاثة آلاف أوروبي..
ربع قِوامهم من البريطانيين وفق صحيفة /الاندبندنت/.. معلومات يبدو أنها تتناغم مع تقرير /دايلي بيست/.. بأن مصدرَ غالبيةِ المقاتلين الأجانب هو بلدان غيرُ مسلمة..  وهم:
- أكثر من سبعمئة فرنسي
- وأكثر من خمسمئة بريطاني
-أكثر من مئة أمريكي
- وحوالي ثلاثمئة وخمسين ألماني وآخرين..
أسباب التحاق أولئك بالتنظيم يلفها الغموض ... في ظل عجز أو ربما تناسي وتغافل حكوماتهم عن التحاقهم بالتنظيم المحظور.
ولا غرو في أن تتبادر إلى الذهن هنا فورا الاستخبارات الأمريكية.. التي لطالما تنصتت على المستشارة الألمانية ورئيسة البرازيل، وربما على كثر غيرهما...
اللافت أيضا أن أجهزة الاستخبارات البريطانية تمكنت من التعرف على شخص مواطنها قاتل الصُحُفي الأمريكي  /جيمس فولي/ من صوته فقط ... فكيف استغفلها حينما كان قريبا منها وبعيدا عن فعلته.
يسأل هنا أيضا في ملف التنظيم عن:
- مستوى تدريبه وإتقانه الفنَ العسكري فضلا عن امتلاكه استراتيجيات الحروب  وخرائطَها والعَتاد الحديث؟
- اقتناؤه لمعلومات استخباراتية دقيقة خاصة بالبلدان التي ينشط فيها وتركيبتها العرقية والطائفية؟
- النشاط في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ونشر المواد المختلفة بشتى اللغات وامتلاكه مجلةً خاصة يشير فحواها إلى أن القائمين عليها محترفون  متخصصون.
- التمويل باتجاهين.
سؤال يبدو ملحا في ضوء سيطرة عناصر التنظيم على حقول نِفطية مهمة ضمن الأراضي التي يسيطر عليها  وفي ظل تقاريرَ تتحدث عن:
- تراجع إنتاج النِفط السوري بنسبة ستة وتسعين في المئة منذ منتصف مارس ألفين وأحد عشر، وذلك من نحو أربعمئة ألف بِرميل يوميا قبل الأزمة إلى أربعة عشر ألف بِرميل يوميا..
وأخرى تتناول-  اتِّجار التنظيم بالذهب الأسود.. وإذا كنا نعرف البائع فمن المشتري؟
وإلى حين معرفة الجواب ستبقى هناك سيولة مالية وبشرية كبيرة تُمد التنظيم بأسباب البقاء.
أسئلة من دون أجوبة ... تبقي الباب مفتوحا على كثير من الافتراضات والتكهنات العاقرة في كثيرها عن تبرير منطقي للنمو السرطاني الذي حققه التنظيم
فأصبح في غضون سنوات ثلاث فقط،  وهو عمر الأزمة السورية، ديناصورا للإرهاب يستدعي استنفار الناتو .